salut aujourd'hui on va faire quelque
chose d'énorme il ya quelques jours je
vous ai demandé sur les réseaux sociaux
celui là celui là celui là et youtube de
me laisser votre prédiction pour 2019
une vraie fausse sélection de voyance ou
une fausse devrait prédictions de
voyance l'idée est que vous me laissiez
votre prédiction pour 2019
mais alors au hasard sans prétendent
avoir de pouvoirs et qu'à la fin de
l'année on vérifie lesquels se sont
réalisées ou pas c'est exactement ce
qu'a fait l'association des sceptiques
du québec pendant plus de vingt ans il
se mesurait pour se marrer aux
astrologues et aux voyants et ensuite
ils voyaient ce qui marche et ou pas
est-ce que ça marchait mieux que les
voyants moins bien que les voyants et
bien au bout de vingt ans de tests
d'essai de vérification ils ont ils
établirent la conclusion suivante
comment se réalise et pour ceux qui met
parfois manqué d'imagination ils ont
même créé un générateur aléatoire
informatisé de prédiction je vous met en
lien dans la description c'est bien
marrant ça va générer une période
un thème un lieu dans le monde et une
prédiction mais ils ont arrêté ce
concept en 2010 est malheureusement tous
les ans il décernait le grand prix
sceptiques il ya des personnes comme le
pharmacien dont je vous invite à aller
voir les vidéos je mets un lien dans la
description qu'ils ont reçus des grands
prix sceptiques lui il a reçu aussi en
2014 pour son esprit critique et
humoristique dans le domaine de la santé
un peu notre détester version québécoise
d'ailleurs je vous mets aussi la chaîne
ii dans ton corps dans la description
abonnez vous ces vidéos sont top
donc je vous propose de relancer ce jeu
cette année sur la chaîne avec
goupilleau prédictions pour 2019
ça fait pas un peu un mix aime ça alors
vos prédictions pour 2019
je vais vous lire quelques prédictions
que vous m'avez laissé sur les réseaux
sociaux des valides pour le concours
concours ougna magazine je le rappelle
quand même mais aussi vos pires
prédictions pour ce mari durant la vidéo
je vous invite à mettre vous aussi votre
prédiction pour 2019 dans les
commentaires alors elle peut être floue
mais elle doit donner un minimum de
précisions par exemple en fin d'année un
ancien politicien va se lancer dans la
chanson et faire un carton même si vous
m'aviez mis une prédiction sur les
réseaux sociaux remettez la dans les
commentaires que je puisse analyser tout
ça en 2020 et qu'on puisse vérifier ce
qui s'est réalisé ou pas de toute
manière je vous hais
il crée comme on fera à la toute fin de
la vidéo maintenant commençons avec vos
dix meilleures prédictions une petite
prédiction pour 2019 première prédiction
julie qui nous dit qu'en 2019 en était
un nuage en forme de coeur va passer au
dessus de la tour eiffel et qui aura un
record de celle fille qui sera pris
exactement à cet endroit
je trouve que c'est une bonne prédiction
de se dire qu'il va y avoir un record de
en tout cas ça remplit les critères
c'est à dire que judith a tout compris
tu nous as donné une période un lieu et
un événement particulier alors il n'y a
peut-être pas de record mais déjà si ça
se passe en tout cas et qui a beaucoup
de cette fille pris à cet endroit
on se souviendra de toi julie deuxième
prédictions et puis carburant mais j'ai
la solution on tâte un tintin taux
d'atteinte voilà je la mets la deuxième
prédiction c'est parti c'est jean yves
qui nous dit donc que le psg va gagner
la ligue des champions que patrick
sébastien bach est sollicité sur ses
limites avec le nouveau grand cabaret
des décès à gogo et blanc caire premier
ministre alors je garde parce que il ya
des trucs où je pense que j'arrive pas
avoir raison par exemple je crois
beaucoup aussi à patrick sébastien sur
ses limites c'est un truc je pense que
cette prédiction peut être bonne mais il
ya beaucoup de prédiction d'un coup
alors là forcément tutu ratisse large
jean-yves mais je comprends pourquoi pas
les voyons aussi font ça ils font plein
de prédiction est comme ça six ans non
il de bonnes dans le tas a pris
européenne juste et bonne foi a mais je
l'avais dit où j'avais pas dit ok j'y
arrive c'est validé troisième
prédictions philippe qui nous dit qu'une
oeuvre d'art va battre un record de
ventes entre fin août et début octobre
ok pas mal philippe je la garde très
simple très basique mais aussi très
efficace l'année dernière il ya déjà eu
une vente de dingue avec le tableau de
comment il s'appelle donc ce qui
exactement
d'ailleurs j'avais une théorie par
rapport à ça parce que je pensais qu'il
n'y ait pas vraiment déchiré qu'il avait
mis un système de magiciens à
l'intérieur qu'ils l'enroulé avec la
partie qui sortait déchire hittites une
partie bon ben c'est apparemment
complètement faux mais ça peut arriver
aux caisses et validé film prédictions
numéro 4
c'est celle de maxime alors maxime
j'hésitais ou classés quand même des
prédictions parce que tu nous dis que
donc en 2019 y ait une personnalité
publique a une grande influence qui va
décéder et que ça va bouleverser
ordre mondial en tout cas sur l'un des
niveaux que tu cites et que ce sera
peut-être même un assassinat on pourrait
penser une grosse blague et en même
temps je me dis pourquoi on validerait
pas ça assez précis pourquoi pas je dis
pas que ça va arriver tu vois je vais
pas commencer à juger vos prédictions en
fait une prédiction est une prédiction
donc je valide sa maxime jeu mais c'est
un potentiel futur validé 5e prédictions
on ne s'arrête plus et celle de kevin
art kevin encore une triple prédictions
mais celle qui m'intéresse c'est celle
qui dit qu'en avril outre aux
catastrophes naturelles doit frapper le
monde alors déjà c'est triste kevin que
tu dis ça mais je la dois lit parce que
ça aussi ça ressemble vraiment aux
prédictions de voyants c'est à peu près
6 en même temps tellement floues les
liera au mois d'avril il ya quand même
oui malheureusement une chance qu'une
catastrophe naturelle quelque part dans
le monde donc vol je le garde je laime
bien celle ci c'est validé 6e
prédictions une prédiction de twitter
une prédiction de frau in front of wind
tu nous dis que elon musk va conquérir
ou du moins lancé un projet pour
conquérir jupiter fin 2019 alors c'est
validé évidemment c'est une bonne
prédiction en floride néanmoins tué
presque trop précis c'est à dire que tu
aurais pas dû m elon musk et aurait dû
mettre des scientifiques vont lancer un
projet pour partir à la conquête de
jupiter voit la fin 2019
ça ça suffirait et a plus de chances que
ça marche quoi valider prédictions
numéro 7 ça ne s'arrête pas ça va à une
vitesse est quand même assez incroyable
indécent c'est encore twitter et ses
mystères signer 133 alors on a encore
plein de prédiction alors on a quattro
qu'un accident on a un bouleversement au
vatican on alla d'égalisation du
cannabis bon je le laisse pas ce que tu
va me servir d'exemple c'est validé
quand même mais vous dans les
commentaires ne m'était qu'une
prédiction par commentaires dans ce cas
l'afsset plusieurs commentaires ce sera
plus simple quand on voudra vérifiait
l'année prochaine ce qui a été fait ou
pas j'ai pas mes fins de phrases allait
valider suivant 8e prédictions alors ça
c'est une prédiction qui a été laissé
dans la zone commentaire de ma page
youtube et alizée nous dit c'est
extrêmement précis je ne sais pas si
c'est une demande une prédiction mais tu
nous dis qu'à partir de fin juin les
élèves n'auront plus à passer le brevet
en france le brevet des collèges en
france tu sais quoi je l'avais dit parce
que c'est bien aussi qu'on ait des
prédictions comme ça très précise via
imagine c'est pas non plus impossible
impossible que le brevet des collèges
soit aboli ou qui a un truc en tout cas
une raison qui fait que ça ne passe pas
alizée tu passes pour la médiane mais
laisse tomber quoi tu vois un truc de
messmer d'à côté c'est eux
non mais ce mardi sera toujours au
dessus validé 9e prédictions toujours
sur ma page youtube la page communauté
dans l'onglet communauté c'est gaëtan
qu'il nous dit alors et c'est un festif
un gaëtan gaëtan c'est en mai tempête
dévastatrice
bah écoute ça fait plaisir un jeu c'est
validé et j'espère que tu auras torre
10e prédictions avant les pires
prédictions c'est une prédiction de
damien alors c'est concis clair précis
pour lui la reine d'angleterre va mourir
les prochaines alors ça peut être les
prédictions aussi un ddc
on va pas faire des paris sur les décès
c'est pas le problème mais je pense
qu'on peut valider ça a quand même dans
les prédictions
c'est pas impossible même si je pense
qu'elle a déjà été remplacé par un robot
voilà chacun son avis
l'ordre mondial est établi à les valider
et deux ans chez dans tout de suite
avait beau père prédictions en 2019
première prédiction
positions laissées sur facebook romain
nous dit que marine le pen passe
convertir à l'islam mais c'est pas tout
elle va aller à strasbourg pour ouvrir
un kebab qui s'appelle à l'alsacienne
jeu équipe il ya beaucoup de trop de
précision donc forcément tu fais partie
des pires et en même temps si c'est vrai
mon bien je m'engage si ça si ça se
passe comme ça allait acheter un bretzel
dans ce kebab et en faire une vidéo une
vidéo que je mettrais partout et que et
dont je remettrai un extrait dans toutes
les vidéos de 2020 voilà deuxièmes pires
prédictions
toujours sur facebook c'est celle de
gérard allard gérard il un petit trip
animalier apparemment donc on aurait des
lapins australien aux yeux fluorescent
et phosphorescent et on aurait aussi des
tortues capable de faire des sont
articulés à cause parce qu'il ya quand
même la cause à cause des relais
hertzien est pour ça qu on passe tout en
numérique d'ailleurs parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que sinon les tortues allez
pouvoir parler et ça c'était ctg gérard
je sais pas si tu voulais faire partie
des pires ou des valides
je t'ai mis dans les pires parce que
dans les hadiths sa murray inquiéter nex
nex nex 3e pierre prédictions
prédictions de marion prédictions simple
et pourtant tellement réaliste alors les
trois quarts je sais pas mais c'est sûr
qu'une partie des étudiants peuvent dire
oui j'ai raté cet examen à cause de
netflix
je peux même vous dire qu'une partie des
youtuber peuvent dire oui j'ai du retard
dans mes vidéos à cause d'une fx une
partie de plein de gens peuvent dire oui
c'est à cause de netflix et du fait que
les séries sont bien et qu'elle sort
chaînes toutes les unes après les autres
alors qu'on amène pas à cliquer quoi que
ce soit quand on perd du temps donc
marion je valide je te donne le grand
prix du pire 4e pires prédictions
j'appuie [ __ ] ubaye d'appuyer la paie pas
et l'appui au quai antoine alors antoine
outre nous nous annonce un nous prévoit
que kurt cobain va annoncer sa tournée
d'été de festival avec michael jackson
elvis presley qui apparemment non il est
pas mort en 2013 en récusant un plein
d'informations extrêmement précise ce
qui me ferait vraiment de marée antoine
sais que tu sais qu'il a maintenant il
ya les concepts des hologrammes
il fut avec mélenchon et tout c'est pas
impossible en fait qu'un jour il ya une
tournée de concerts comme ça deux
anciens chanteurs qui sont qui sont eux
qui ont disparu si ça se lance cette
année et que c'est kurt cobain michael
jackson elvis presley qui sont à la
fiche je suis trois mois mort de rire
annexes chaque pierre prédictions
prédictions de bernard non je la regarde
même pas je ne faisais même pas si je la
lis je bâtis quand même bon ils vont
quand même pas sortir des préservatifs
encore moins au goût au ch'ti en même
temps ce serait pratique peut-être pour
absoudre son péché n'est que 10e pires
prédictions
une prédiction de twitter une prédiction
de pictet qui annonce donc que dire que
les pains au chocolat seront interdits
que macron à voter une loi et qu'on est
tous obligés de dire chocolatines bas de
toute manière on va pas relancer un
débat moi j'aime la rochelle
personnellement donc les pains au
chocolat c'est un doute pas avec un
morceau de chocolat dedans donc c'est
pour ça que ça fait partie des prix de
production parce que de base on dit une
chocolatine donc la septième pire pire
pires prédictions la queue sur twitter
que je peux dire d'être comme ça
martin indyk le 7 mars prochain des
ninjas rocha venant de l'espace commandé
par silva du rif vont renverser le
gouvernement bolivien evo créer une
entreprise de transport maritime qui va
bouleverser l'ordre mondial
la bolivie n'a pas d'accès à la mer mais
ils s'en foutent
qu'est-ce que je dise là dessus il ya un
moment donné
toi et moi on sait qu'en ce moment toi
ça va pas trop est ce que tu veux en
parler dans les commentaires est ce que
tu veux qu'on crée un forum pour toi de
soutien et des coûts d'un numéro vert
peut-être pour ça
ce jeu je suis pour mais huitième des
pires prédictions maintenant prédictions
apparu sur l'onglet communauté de monju
tube par dur au dodo heavy qui nous dit
on été 2019 le télescope hubble observe
la terre et découvre qu'elle est plate
et que les autres photos ont été prises
de travers je l'attends le concept
en fait toutes les autres on avait un
peu mal cadrée dans a bien bien cadré
écoute c'est bien ce qui fait partie des
pires prédictions tu t'attendais à quoi
néanmoins si jamais tu avais raison
je t'offre ma chaîne secondaire je
m'engage à t'offrir match n secondaire
c'est la chaîne fabien euros post-it
master ya qu une seule vidéo je te
l'offre à les portois si la terre est
vraiment plate forme le prouver mon gars
tu peux même faire une vidéo pour
essayer de me trouver vous pouvez vous y
mettre à plusieurs plats avoir des
arguments solides pour m'expliquer que
toutes les autres est éprise de travers
next 9e on s'approche de la fin 9e pires
prédictions
car prédictions de vos prédictions à
vous pour 2019
et c'est encore un commentaire apparues
sur youtube dans l'onglet d'anglais dans
l'onglet je peux le dire à chaque fois
en devenir février 2019
le général tu nous dis que trump
déclassifie de l'ensemble des dossiers
extraterrestes depuis la sphère roswell
et qui s'adresse à l'humanité lors d'un
flash spécial diffusé et repris sur les
chaînes télévisées du monde entier
expliquant que les extraterrestres sont
en contact permanent avec nous depuis
plus de 60 ans c'est précis nous
apprenons l'existence d'une alliance
intergalactique et bien organisée le
président des états unis d'amérique
étant le porte parole de la race humaine
sur terre écoute dans ton futur
potentiel j'espère juste quand même
qu'on n'aurait changé de président des
états unis d'amérique entre temps c'est
juste quand je vois les relations que
peu à voir trump avec ses collègues
présidents dans le monde entier je juge
pas un mais je me dis peut-être pas le
meilleur porte parole grain aller next
ou la dixième pires prédictions
je sais laquelle j'avais mis en dernier
je sais que c'est celle de thérèse que
thérèse m'a laissé sur youtube et
thérèse c'est très simple
la france va devenir la belgique
voilà et on n'a même pas de comment
pourquoi comment la france devient la
belgique est juste une eta bien comme il
faut
ben écoute d'accord je vous rappelle que
maintenant vous devez mettre dans les
commentaires votre prédiction à vous
pour 2019 jamais été qu'une seule
prédiction par commentaires ce sera plus
simple après en 2020 pour moi de faire
leur tour si durant l'année votre
prédiction se réalise vos revenus sur la
vidéo vous allez sur votre commentaire
vous fait répondre et vous me mettez un
lien vers un site d'info en tout cas un
lien vers quelque chose qui prouve que
votre prédiction s'est réalisée comme ça
ce sera parfait pour la vidéo d'un
prochaine mais attention je vous vois
venir
je vous connais je ne prendrai pas en
compte les commentaires qui ont été
modifiées durant l'année trop je vous
connais d'ailleurs si cette vidéo vous a
plu n'oubliez pas de lalique et vous
pouvez aussi vous abonner à la chaîne si
c'est pas encore fait si vous n'êtes pas
abonné c'est important pour moi pour mon
travail est pour vous pour ne pas rater
les prochaines vidéos un petit peu comme
celle ci que youtube voir comment nous
sommes sur la dernière que j'ai sorti
sur la chaîne je pense également à me
suivre sur facebook twitter un stade
pour participer aux vidéos participative
du coup c'est assez normal merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo à très bientôt
ciao